it
oh oh
1983 was the answer oh God I forgot I
actually need to play this and finish it
out oh good lord hello everybody my name
is Markiplier welcome back to Five
Nights at Freddy's Help Wanted 2 it's a
wonderful day to explore the world
of this wonderful game once more and
realize that I was a big dumb dummy what
is down the hallway what in the hell are
whoa okay never mind then get off of
there uhhuh so we got balora coming down
the right side we just got
to no thanks so we're going to get
through this one and then we only have
one other clue that's still written
there and I'm very smart with my
gigantic brain and and I can figure that
out whoa oh I see you there I see you
there I don't like that I see you there
wish I could give you a controlled Chun
okay good to know so you're coming down
the center
channel
crap that means I got to be ready on
this that's
okay all right we got bore on the right
as
well two CL who nope God that's both of
them okay good to know hey get off of
there get
don't you're good you're good probably
not great on power but not the worst
thing that's ever happened not great not
terrible oh there more than one of you
oh I saw you
there come on 3:00 come
on let's get through this
freaking get whoa who where whoa no
thank you okay all right I hear I
thought I heard some electricity
going okay I was not paying attention to
that which is not
great there now it's three okay A little
choked on power but oh God I forgot
about that I'm not going to be able to
get through this if I keep doing
mistakes like that we got this guy
crawling up the center nobody in the
sides
yet come on oo I do not like it when it
does
[Music]
that you're coming down the center again
we got power
slurpers you're good Center channel oh
you're standing now look at you aren't
you just a big
boy big annoying boy oh go that was
quick I'm pretty sure that ends what
freaking get off of there go get out of
here
a-holes I see you down at the end of the
hallway there balora as much as you
would probably like mean not to be but I
do see that be I be do the I I be do
that who's there you there away away
okay come on five I need I need more
this is a bit of a tight window to be
able to survive all this you're coming
down that way five good good good great
good great you're coming down that way
oh freak get off of
there no get off
there whoa what was that did I hear a
knocking thought I heard a knocking
better not be a knocking ah freak get
out
okay all right 155 a.m. not bad that
might be the last middle one that we get
for the night but we also might get one
more
balora nope maybe not unless you're
already here which I don't like the idea
of
that okay what are we looking at was it
there oh never mind I'm the best that
ever lived okay good so we got that
which means that we got one more of
these weird voodoo
dolls great it's that going to be in the
hub or is that one of the models that
pops up through the floor because again
one of those is going to jump out of me
oh
oh that was you I can't even pick you up
num num num num okay so that was that
doesn't make a lot of sense except for
the fact that balora was in that one one
so that means that I've got this clue
here which is sodon in a
graveyard which the only is that
actually was there actually a graveyard
in fazer blast I feel like there was
wasn't
there okay no wait
on it has the Aesthetics of ominousness
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's a graveyard right this is not
necessarily a graveyard whoopsies H you
know what I'll I'll finish it anyway
damn it I'm not hitting any of those
behind the scenes whoa
rocket wait a minute
rocket oh no not now what are you doing
why would you be crashing now oh oh my
god oh oh my God wait we're back whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa what the what the
freak just happened what give get what
just
happened oh
where where was that God damn it
where was that you go
away all right winner don't get
your I will thank you okay so that did
something I forgot about the uh oh
what I'm freaking sorry what what was
that why did that happen why am I back
here that does what that plan ah what I
I I don't even did that undo what I just
did what that doesn't make any sense
there was a rocket ship I shot a rocket
ship why did that
happen why would that have happened I
know there's a rocket ship in like every
one of
these
right well I'm sure we can buy something
so the hay Bale's still there the hay
bale that fell down before is still
there oh freck not oh well yeah I'm I'm
I screwed that
up maybe I should just stick with
[Music]
these no but we got purples over there
oh well I'm forgetting okay well this is
going
terrible are you laughing at me is that
guy laugh well I've done absolutely
atrociously thus
far
ah okay I only just heard the laugh why
is that like aggressive that seems
egregiously
[Music]
aggressive I don't know where you went
where are you where there you
are oh shoot
[Music]
well
okay I got the rocket chip that's nice
whoa what the hell oh my
God okay well that's
interesting whoa whoa I saw you coming
at me you look like you got kid put a
prize for the little one uh-huh next
time bring the whole family
for uh-huh all right so I think I did
something there the rocket ship went out
I can't believe I missed that each time
before but that must mean
o that if I get the rocket every single
time on this then it's going to mean
something right that's still there yeah
interesting oh yeah this this whole
thing right so I have to evaluate I'm no
this is not going to work I just need to
reposition because it's not going to
work that way if I if I keep going there
[Music]
okay whoa what was
that whoa what the quick wao that's
weird oh my God what the hell was that
whoa I don't remember that at all whoa
[Music]
hi this is
weird oh I see did I what the freak is
it oh my God whoa wait a minute what was
that what the hell is ah
freak right right yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I didn't really understand what was
going on here so what happens is every
time you
get you get a
chance okay well I don't know what that
was about I'm literally playing Five
Nights at Freddy's 2 in
this which is just a fascinating
experience okay so you're there what
does that
mean okay oh boy what do I do about that
oh right of course the freaking balloons
of
course so mangles up that
way oh that's how I get most
points right okay that makes
sense this is weird Okay so what I have
to
do is just at all
times it's about checking the cameras
where's balloon boy wow that's weirdly
topical and then check the front check
the sides clear these guys out well that
should have
counted a okay we're okay shockingly
okay
I did it for the whole
family I didn't see a rocket ship
though the little wait but I I didn't
see any there was
no there wasn't a rocket but I didn't
get any
rocket but I didn't see a
rocket oh nice and let me try that again
cuz now that I'm getting a hang of what
this actually wants me to do it's going
to be a little easier to work
through
that's definitely the way to get maximum
points for
sure who my God oh my God wait wait wait
wait
whoa oh my
God my God okay give me
that whoa oh forgot about that
that's
okay whoa ah shoot that shoot that okay
I did
it know
that
ha there you are come here
you don't forget about that now I'm
starting to get it
whoa my God hello friend
okay better better better doing
better I heard
that oh there you
are
oh hey I still didn't see a rocket
ship whoa whoa whoa
whoa hold on I'm on fire I'm on
fire hold on I'm on
fire okay uh
uh ice screen poster stay cool great did
that do
it no okay so what did that have to do
with a rocket
ship did that unlock oh FNAF 3 where you
going don't let a little fire stop the
fun come on back well you know at first
I was like kind of iffy on the whole
oh
oh oh no oh I got to do everything well
this might be a little difficult you
know at first I was iffy on the whole oh
my God are you
okay how how you feeling Bud oh where am
I where where exactly am I
shooting oh man okay uh oh hi oh uh well
hold on take that oh one of these all
right well let me hold on all right
eventually I'm okay I guess I didn't get
you at all well that okay well this is
problematic
how oh hello H take that oh God damn it
go
away aha aha there's that a balloon ah
where where go
away okay now I'm starting to get it
took me a
second not today oh there you are oh oh
oh oh nice eyeballs yo
oh I see okay wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
wait those a I thought the eyes might
have been targets for a second there it
is kind of easier if I just try
to right in the grundle ah that was
going right for your leg go
away
curveball
nice where'd you
go not
today why don't you show me your other
leg
huh
where there's your other leg okay and
that one okay that should be everything
I think oh oh he's got a Target on his
heart oh no no no no oh my God
hello I'll take that yeah
before
uh
oh freak yes that's what I'm talking
about I don't want that okay so somehow
I've stumbled into Victory but that's is
because my gaming expertise of years has
led me to this point where I think that
qualifies as beating yep and that oh
there you are Freddy huh well nice to
meet you you look kind of like
helpie you going to have a
problem I hope not I would hate to have
a problem with you that would be the the
worst thing I think we could be friends
I think we could be very good friends so
why don't you not ruin anything and just
let me be friends with you and that way
everything can be fine and nothing will
ever be a problem again okay
T I believe everything else was or at
least it ended up being in the real
world without the mask on so it's got to
be this one no that's where the other
one
was that's where the and
is the clue to the kitchen was in that
one so it's not that one where's our
graveyard what is that saying there's
something on
there is that lightning bolt no power
lightning
bolt lightning bolt
rip M for Markiplier okay so it's got to
be something to do with no power or
don't use power or something like that
no
power I had the weirdest thought it's
kind of like food prep I'm not even
there yet that's right I'm not there yet
make the correct order Purge button
watch out for
chica cuz if you think about it I was
always wondering what that last camera
was about and it's basically a graveyard
well that might be stretching it a bit
but there was always something about
that camera that didn't make any sense
because why was it there it's trash okay
I need caffeine and I need one more
sugar in
there could I not drink
that
oh wait did
I what is what is this send it out hi
what's up oh yeah sorry I'm I'm not
doing it hold on things are going ay C
sugar salt that's new okay we'll send
that out in the mome okay you take a
break you double time double time double
time you're going to take a
break uh send that
out I think there's a sodon here why is
there a sodon there
sodon sodon I have to give Chica the
sodon right what was the power thing
there was something about power I don't
remember what
whoa what was that what was that what
was
that ah my salt spoiled how does
salt
spoil what what
Jackass send it
out oh chica wait wait hold on what what
do I do about that come on come on come
on what was that about chica oh
okay here we go caffeine caffeine sugar
salt salt send it out you take a break
salt give me more I need you ah
this better have acid yes it did okay
but I need a lot more salt okay one
second salt on the double don't do it oh
my God what are you doing
there
wait go faster I'm locking down I don't
know what this is
about okay are we all back in our spots
or what's the
deal oh oh no wait hold on hold on a
second yes
hello what what are you
doing
crap oh boy um I don't know what to do
about that hold on you just spoiled my
sugar didn't you no that was my own
fault I'm not going to make this
one maybe
if I can get one more ah you're on break
okay that's not working okay whatever
damn
it okay yeah I get that that makes a lot
of sense grab this block and job start
now be there something to do with this
ingredients May attract unwanted pests
what does that even mean I don't know
what that means okay hold
on it does a thing okay all right so
that does something
that does something and it said no
lightning that might mean no caffeine so
if I
put
no did that do it did that do anything
no okay hold on there's something here
cuz putting that in actually does
something start now if I dump it in the
trash then that's that's going to go to
the trash doing ingredients May attract
May attct yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I put this in
okay that's in there then I
do salt sugar
lemon that's a colorful thing I dump
it and what happens oh she's up she's up
oh she's up oh she is up okay but what
what about
that okay did that do what I needed it
to do did that do what it needed to do I
don't know if that did what it needed to
do I I don't know hold on yeah okay all
right hold on I'm going to something
something um cuz usually if you do
something right it does instantaneous
feed back and job start now and it's not
about drinking this so you have this
maybe is there like a certain order that
you need to do it
in no
okay so that's not it there's something
here I'm on the cusp cuz it was
sodon graveyard no lightning it said no
to the lightning which makes me think
it's not May attract unwanted pests it
makes me think I guess wait no as far as
instantaneous results go technically
speaking
well whatever oh oh oh well all right
that's
fine so that gets her up right
away is that good is that good I don't
know if that's actually
good come on salt salt salt there we go
got
it okay I need sugar to take a break
after after this because it's too
productive
okay sugar caffeine acid acid protein
Chuck it in
whoa okay you take a
break I need caffeine God damn oh what
are you
doing what are you I don't even know
what you're doing okay this one salt
salt salt protein acid acid okay we're
good okay I need
n my
God oh my God okay all right
wow this acid acid no caffeine sugar
need caffeine next okay caffeine we got
to
go okay let's go let's go I don't know
what to do about that besides initiate a
lockdown come on caffeine there we go
okay we good there okay you take a break
come on caffeine let's spill it up we
need no more sugar no more sugar oh God
I hope there's sugar in there damn it
okay let's dump
that okay you're going on break salt
salt protein protein salt please we need
more salt come
on
please please ah you go on break oh
freak God damn it all right well that
sucks ah dump
that okay we need sugar ah frick protein
and then acid please acid we got to go
there we
are all right yeah you go on break you
go on break speed it up you do not speed
it up sugar please sugar
sugar caffeine caffeine acid good we're
good there so let's moderate the
sugar where we need definitely need acid
okay so we're moderating the
sugar go and send it out actually so
you're going to double speed need
protein on double Salt's
okay salt salt salt salt protein protein
send it out please go on a break I know
I'm sending everyone else on a break but
holy crap freck well that's just a
problem we need more one more assing oh
my God holy
okay hopefully it's got sugar
caffeine caffeine salt and one more salt
okay we need salt up we need these up we
need sugar to go on a break we need you
to
go somewhere salt put it in go good all
right what do we need you can go on a
break
okay I don't think I did it same time
tomorrow that's the thing I don't think
I actually did it I don't think I did
the thing that I was supposed to
do fruit punch clown
great good that's what I need in my life
all right sodon in a graveyard rest in
peace I don't know what that means I'm
going to figure it out in the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching we're getting very close cuz
really there's actually not that many
left to do there's another
office that's
done that's done we need music
man we got another fizzy fast oh another
fizzy Fast Night o maybe I didn't get to
it maybe that's where it needs to happen
so I'm getting really close here not
quite there yet but I'll probably get
there in the next episode if everything
goes smooth which it will thank you
again and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]
bye-bye